orally active clinically translatable
cenolitics restore alpha clotho in mice
and humans
so there you go that's the video boom
i'm joking let's take a look at this
paper in more detail
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where we will first
introduce these elusive clothing
proteins talk about ceneolytics and look
at how this paper brought these two
areas together so firstly then what are
cloth a proteins
well this is the first time i've
mentioned clotho on this channel though
i've been meaning to talk about them for
a while
so clothes proteins are proteins that
are found at the cell membrane the gene
encoding the protein was first uncovered
in a mouse strain that displayed a
complex aging phenotype suspected to be
caused by genetic alteration disrupting
a putative aging suppressor gene
and because clotho is the name of one of
the goddesses of destiny in greek
mythology who spins the thread of life
the name was co-opted for this gene
but it turns out there is more than one
gene for cloth a proteins there are in
fact two cloth proteins alpha and beta
the proteins are not expressed in all
cell types and are primarily expressed
in the kidney a region of the brain and
a bit in adipose tissue
they act to promote high affinity
binding of specific fibroblast growth
factors to their receptors
and despite their name
the fibroblast growth factors that
interact with clothing proteins are more
modest growth factors and are instead
involved in endocrine functions
that is they can diffuse into the
systemic circulation away from their
source of production
alpha clotho since this is the one we'll
be talking about in the rest of this
video binds to fibroblast growth factor
23
this interaction mediates several
processes including regulating phosphate
and calcium levels and the health of
kidneys and bones
in fact alde cloth is most abundant in
the kidneys though as i mentioned
earlier it is also present in part of
the brain
anyway lack of alpha-clopha causes
phosphate imbalance
phosphate in the form of calcium
phosphate is important for bones
however whilst i told you it's a
membrane protein
which it is the exterior part of alpha
clotho can get cleaved and you can get
soluble alkalotho this can be detected
in the serum of blood and urine and is
indicative of the total expression of
alpha cloth oh this knowledge will
become relevant later
so it appears that alpha clothing
appears to be an important protein
and studies seem to suggest that alpha
clothing goes down with aging
and as that goes down with aging
something else increases the presence of
senescent cells
now my speedy senescence cell recap
senescent cells are cells that have
entered a sulfate whereby they no longer
divide and develop the potential to
secrete a variety of factors into the
external environment we refer to this as
the senescent associated secretory
phenotype
these include many different factors of
which some include inflammatory factors
and whilst their chronic presence could
contribute to
continued inflammation and
and has therefore been linked to
different diseases
senescent cells aren't all bad and are
useful in wound healing and development
and acting as a tumor-suppressive
mechanism
but anyway just because there is a
correlation albeit in fast correlation
between alpha cloth a levels and
tenacity cell abundance it doesn't prove
causation but this now brings me on to
this latest publication orally active
clinically translatable analytics
restore alpha clotho in mice and humans
so what did they do in the study
well firstly the authors took the sasp
the secretory phenotype of the senescent
cells and put them on some relevant
human cell lines
endothelial cells kidney cells and brain
astrocytes so cells that produce
alkalophobe and well they saw the levels
decline
a reduction also occurred with just
singular components of the sasp
a and active a suggesting that these
factors are involved in causing the
decline in clothing expression
they even took this one step further by
transplanting senescent cells into young
mice and found that it decreased alpha
clothing levels in the brain and urine
but targeting the sasp is just one
mechanism to work out the connection
but why not just eliminate all of the
sasp or better why not just get rid of
the senescent cells and see what happens
well this is what they did
and so here they used so-called
psenolithics drugs that selectively kill
senescent cells and they use the already
reported combination of the sasatinib
and quercetin as well as fetidine and
they've detected increased altaclopto in
the urine and kidney in aged mice
it's worth pointing out though that
synalytics didn't increase alpha clotho
in the urine of young mice most likely
because senescent cell levels are low in
young mice and so
clearing them has a minimal impact on
the alpha clothing levels
and so this does also support the fact
that senescent cells are maybe the cause
for the reductions in alpha clothing
with age
but this is a mice what about some human
data
well they analyzed the previously
conducted trial that treated patients
with idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis with
nine doses of disaster and quercetin
over three weeks
in this trial the treatment improved
functional aspects such as increased
distance and speed
and they also found that this correlated
with increased urinary levels of alpha
clotho so in line with the mouse data
it's worth pointing out as well that the
use of analytics here to boost alpha
clothing levels
has the practical advantage of using the
synolytic hit-and-run strategy as
opposed to finding ways of repeatedly
somehow administering alpha clotho
it also could mean that alpha cloth a
levels as detected in the urine could be
one way of measuring the efficacy of
different cenolitics
so what are the take-homes well given
that i study senescent cells it's always
interesting to hear more about their
influence i think here it proves some
elements of causation and the
involvement of specific sas components
in influencing the expression of this
important protein alpha clotho which
could link it to phosphate imbalance and
the consequences of that such as in
kidney malfunction and potentially
osteoporosis
that occurs of age
but i still think there are some
elements to understanding the molecular
mechanism that irons are explored here
but frankly i don't think i know enough
about clothing proteins and their
regulation to give a clever answer but
clothing proteins are indeed some
proteins that i will be keen to learn
more about
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening